Argentina está padeciendo la peor ola de
calor en seis décadas así lo ha
expresado el servicio meteorológico
nacional el cual emitió alertas por
temperaturas extremas en nueve
provincias del centro y el norte del
territorio y le pidió a los ciudadanos
que tengan cuidados especiales curando
estar siempre en lugar con sombra con
aire así que cuidándome pero hago
gimnasia bajo un árbol
cuando camino no pudo llevar gorros
sombrero hay que cuidarse Esta es la
octava ola de calor que afecta a la
nación Sudamericana acostumbrada a
recibir entre 4 y 5 en esta etapa del
año las temperaturas sofocantes también
llegaron a la Patagonia Argentina que
alcanzó los 42 grados en la costa de Río
negro durante la última semana sí
tenemos varios que están acá y
dice que la temperatura de calor en
verano era muy fuerte se quejaban mucho
y
era sofocante y no no no no entendíamos
hasta que estamos viviendo ahora la
realidad
me gusta el calor pero estos calores son
demasiado fuertes ya yo soy partidaria
del calor porque en invierno su alergia
y estoy todo el invierno estornudando
estoy mal y me gusta el calor pero este
calor me ha llegado a decir que calor el
servicio meteorológico aseguró que los
meses de noviembre a enero fueron los
más cálidos desde 1961 también generaron
sequías en los campos arruinando
alrededor de la mitad de la producción
de soja y maíz de la temporada algo que
repercutirá en la golpeada economía
nacional